il a dit ouais je reconnais que j'étais
surpris je me demandais pourquoi le pull
en laine j'enfilé puis c'est des cris
d'animaux
maintenant Gaspard Proust pour elle est
pas belle la vie
bon l'actualité en ce moment c'est super
chargé évidemment avant toute chose
cette polémique
cette troisième place de Lopes compteur
d'eau sur ktm face à Elder Rodrigues sur
Honda au Paris Dakar
non meilleur l'étape d'hier entre San
Juan et shilichito c'était du beauté
quoi j'ai jamais aussi bien dormi de ma
vie quoi sinon ce qui se passe en France
bien sûr il y a ce moment il fait pas
bon avoir le mot Dieu dans son patronyme
c'est
toujours été un peu comme ça sous la
gauche Dieu le veut Depardieu Dieudonné
je serais donne Dieu de vape je
changerai le code de mon immeuble
mais chose plus dur loisir de montagne
on a retrouvé les images filmées par la
caméra GoPro Tsumi
ce que c'est beau Méribel
c'est
un film assez court et c'est un peu
frustrant parce qu'au début on filme le
domaine skiable et puis d'un coup je
comprends pas pourquoi le mec qui filme
cet avion qui passe
il reste une heure comme ça tu dis bon
vas-y tourne un peu tu vois tu as envie
de voir les soins
au ski les Allemands c'est ils ont au
minimum deux étoiles en allemand tu n'as
qu'une étoile c'est un peu suspect quoi
c'est
une provocation
je pense
on Schumi qui se blesse au ski Merkel au
ski de fond depuis Stalingrad ils
auraient quand même dû comprendre que la
neige c'est pas pour eux quoi
mais dans l'actu c'est aussi des
nouvelles très dramatiques un truc qui
m'a héros à survécu la nouvelle année
non mais il a même fait des vœux il a
parlé alors plus d'attaque que jamais
avec son air de chef de meute là comme
ça moi j'ai si héros a passé l'hiver la
droite je sais pas si vous allez en 2013
la droite s'est couchée avec un lumbago
en 2014 j'ai travaillé avec une sclérose
en plaques c'est pas possible dans le
coup de grâce a été les vœux du
président enfin qu'est ce qui vous a mis
dans la tronche
oui on va baisser les charges on va
faire un pack avec le Medef avec des
abus à la sécu faut plus de
compétitivité moins d'impôts
ça m'a fait penser à une réunion
d'alcoolique anony moi un moment le psy
il dit bon les gars en fait on va
arrêter de se mentir laisser tomber les
médocs on repasse à la vodka
parce que
politique toujours municipale à Paris on
sent qu'à Paris ça fonctionne bien pour
une
surtout si le projet de découvrir le
crack avec Pitt Doherty
j'ose pas imaginer ce que c'est pris en
rentrant chez eux
attends moi je vois ma copine fumée à
une clope avec un SDF avant de la
toucher je la mets aux toilettage pour
chien enfin je fais quelque chose
chômage Nabilla s'est fait enlever ses
prothèses c'est malheureux la jeunesse
française et les passives inconsciente
de son talent et puis le jour où elle
prend conscience qu'elle en a un la
première chose qu'elle veut faire c'est
de le supprimer
[Applaudissements]
justice à moi de sursis et 150 euros
d'amende pour une dame qui portait le
nicab ça va trop loin maintenant non
mais handicap c'est pas très grand 150
euros ça va quand même vachement cher la
taxe d'habitation
après faut le porter mais c'est cher
divers alors un homme a mis le feu à sa
femme avant de se défénestrer avec son
fils j'ai vu ça comme quoi il faudrait
aussi penser interdire les castings pour
la France un incroyable talent
bonne nouvelle on a retrouvé le zoophile
responsable de la mort de plusieurs
moutons près de Perpignan en fait il
était bourré il a dit ouais je reconnais
que j'étais surpris je me demandais
pourquoi le pull en laine j'enfilé puis
c'est des cris d'animaux
[Applaudissements]
alors
les parents cachemire la vie et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu